hey I'm back I really hope this works
I'm on my grandma's Internet just got to
Palm Springs yesterday and I'm about to
play the Rena Kings tournament which
I've never met never actually played
before but it's a tournament
specifically for streamers so it starts
in just under a minute I'm gonna check
to make sure the stream looks okay if
that's even possible there we go
Oh Braden's here i'm singers here let me
know if you can hear me okay and let me
know if it's not lagging because that
would be nice
seems like there's a good turnout
there's 50 players I actually don't know
if that's a good turnout for this
tournament but there is several players
above me Eric Hanson is playing many of
these players I haven't heard of before
killer mania what's seen in high wait
where am I
why don't I see myself that was strange
okay well I'm playing some guy TM mouse
key well it's not Swiss parings I guess
cool yeah hello NZ hello Braden hello
I'm singer hello anacott yeah this is
new for me I'm on chess calm it took me
about like 20 minutes to setup the
stream layout so hopefully it looks okay
Bishop d2 not a common move c5 is the
most I'm addict response challenge d4
maybe 96 and maybe I just take with
Bishop eventually let's castle my
biggest weakness with streaming and
playing blitz is moving too slowly so
I'm gonna try and not play too slowly at
night a 6 let's just take the pawn the
bishops misplaced knight c6 I guess
and I know I remember there's a trap
here I'm wondering if I can somehow do
the trap Queen c7 let's start with Queen
c7 the trap is when he plays before I go
back to e7 and a5 can be very strong
later and usually white underestimates
the power of a5 I'm hoping it works in
this position because now there's some
positional play to c5 square and it
looks very slow for black like the
knight retreats and black is a little
bit slow to develop if I can play like
d6 97-95 terrible at drawing arrows but
you guys get the point
oh let's play 97 I've played the
structure before and it's usually pretty
Pleasant like a lot of these moves I can
play quickly right rook c8 rook da Queen
be a queen aids and sometimes White has
a hard time figuring out what to do
the first follow thank you thank you
Karen I wonder if that's a real caring
probably is a real Karen from the
Atlanta Chess Club appreciate that it's
been fine goal playing this it's very
good question Oh Queen b8 I guess no
Queen b8 I don't know
leaves b6 undefended then this Knight is
overworked
let's just play age six he fell asleep
then finally fell asleep
that would be tragic okay I can play
Queen b8 and just slowly move around is
there increments I don't even know the
time control I don't know where it says
the time control b6 is weak let's go
back like where does it say the time
control play no increment okay that's
really good to know I thought there is
increments I thought it was just the
same as like typos Tuesday I guess not
okay I'm gonna have to flag this guy
now I have the D file let's threaten
sneaky tricks
I just want to provoke weaknesses like
if he plays g3 I'm slightly happier
place I for I'm slightly more happier
just trying to tickle him
okay now I'll retreat and now e4 is a
target this bishops happy tonight we'll
probably have to go back to f6 let's
start with rook d7 do stuff like this
it's a tricky position it's going to
come down down to some time kind of a
time scramble so I have to keep up the
tempo some kind of battery on a D file
we're probably just gonna trade off a
bunch of stuff on the D file I really
like this bishop especially like this
pawn can't move backwards so ephors a
constant target I know
now this diagonal is fully open I'm
using the player up d1 kind of annoying
Queen d3 also kind of annoying g6 only
move rook T it's coming though or not
wait what is he threatening it's not
threatening anything just play they're a
scary position though what do I do
I'm people ship at three tack the rook
take take you may take and play rook to
e8 and maybe a whole Bunder is rook on
b7 he plays rook c7 I play rook d2 so
he'll probably take and then I have to
flag him
maybe g5 at some point he wants to trade
Bishop's I don't want to trade bishops
put the bishop on d3 if he plays Bishop
f3 okay g5 I have to open the position
if the position opens up the two bishops
will be king and he's low on time now
that's good he wants to trade bishops
again stop it Bishop h1 he's attacking
me let's play King g7 defending
everything the bishop will go somewhere
at some points it's by h5 he's gonna
play Bishop b4 I still don't want to
trade like that's the rule when you have
two bishops don't trade off bishops yes
even though they're not too impressive
right now they might be impressive later
so this is scary cuz my t6 is coming I
have to play Bishop d7 and move the pawn
somewhere here oh no I got four okay
it's gonna be a time scramble I have to
fly again
now when you pre move on chess con does
it wastes time so I hope it does that
would give me better flagging chances
this is really unpleasant my bishop
stuck my King stuck is that meat that's
almost means this is painful this is
really painful
please flag please [ __ ] yes yes okay I
got a points next game wait oh it's like
it's likely chess we start automatically
I thought it was a swiss tournament can
i bezerk I've never done this on chess
calm I thought like we wait till all the
games finished wait I'm so confused now
so it's just how long is this tournament
is that 120 minutes or an hour and 12
minutes if someone can please explain
the floor mats breathe in saying
something check I'm sign-in oh just calm
Simon this year I think I've seen that
guy before I assume it's not Simon
Williams maybe it is so it runs two
hours okay
might be fives the principal move and
then the night on b5 versus not on e6
it's a it's a nice matchup this night is
stuck for a long time and then I think
the plan is to play like 95 Bishop e2 a4
can be thrown in start with Bishop e2 no
so I get more points for streaks so I
have a streak of one game doesn't sound
too impressive so I should I should be
able to see like the leaderboard
I see the German standings oh I'm in
18th place so how do you uh how do you
berserk is their bizarre King options
oh you can't bezerk okay I answered that
question
that's three maybe oh I had a fork I
still have a fork that's a nice fork so
what happens when your pieces are in
good squares it's probably a good thing
that I can't physic I'll stay calm I
won't get tilted or if I do get tilted I
won't get you even more tilted and this
is a nice position you should just
resign and then we can play another game
or he's gonna fight on which I respect
that
let's play rookie one target the pawn
rook e8 I can start trading everything
take take take
wait it has me tactics here take take I
can take on a seven to take on a seven
it's a free pawn promises rooks defended
by everything I wanted to like use cut
some kind of pin but it doesn't work now
why does it say join it just switched
wrong I don't know what it was saying
before did I leave the tournament was
going on join ok now I'm wondering
because I'm confused with what it's
saying but maybe that wasn't a blunder
if I can take there well he can fork me
on no he can't afford me the Knights
pinned ok if someone could explain
what's going on here like this is very
very new for me ok I'm gonna click next
game oh ok so I'm still in the
tournament
that's strange so it was saying join but
I was I'm I'm already in the tournament
and I'm tied for fourth place I guess
I'm playing let wgm Leslie so
interesting ok let's move
oh he's playing a London or she is
playing a London I'm gonna play this
line I do usually play with 6
I'll play the Wesley so line taken ith 5
oops I didn't want to play 9h 5 right
away
oops ok still getting used to the nature
of pre moving here neither force coming
maybe not at for now attack castle
yeah g3g three is a bit weakening though
because light scores could be vulnerable
a bit later I would like to play e5 here
it but it gives me an IQ P it also
probably loses upon I mean I'll minority
attack I take with Queen and like do
this stuff I think I'm okay taking again
maybe f6 okay this guy's playing very
fast to keep up the pace it's an
interesting structure so I'm not sure
what's better like the bishop or the
Knights but at least black has this
clear plan of creating weaknesses I'll
start with rook FCA to probably do this
and this and this just have to watch out
for the Kings side let's start with
before ah a knight c5 is coming and
Bishop a4 doesn't work
mmm and I have to sack okay
I'll probably sack on c5 it's not what I
wanted I mean I could cocoon but that's
no fun thing is it's not that bad to be
done in exchange because White's king is
open the rooks have no infiltration
promise it's a long term material
advantage for black or for whites
let's not trade Queens lightly Queen a5
hit the pawn maybe I'll play rook c8 and
then put the rook on c4 c4 he's being
aggressive but I can take my defend d5
it's gonna get a bit crazy well I could
I could play rugby too as well like rook
b2 coming thank you Lord Kinbote 999 I
appreciate the follow Rick b2 might be a
good move if he takes because I'm I'm
threatening all sort
some eighths on the second-ranked and
like he doesn't have too much time here
if he plays Ricky - I just take on c4
Vereen is asking a question but I read
too slowly I'll try and answer the
question a bit later have to focus in
this position it's a critical moment for
white currently there's two threats
Queen takes e4 and rook b2 rook b2 still
looks good I mean it looks crazy I mean
Queenie for as possible but then I take
on each two sometimes positions like
this if you can get the initiative first
it's just going to be much better or
winning I have the time advantage and
white keeps thinking that's a good sign
wonder if he's gonna like SAC somehow or
maybe he'll play a move like rook c3 and
then no like I was thinking he could
move the rook and defend f2 never mind
could take on h2 but then Ricky - is
possible that's probably good cuz I can
take on d5 and end and I have like four
pawns for the exchange or three pawns
for the exchange take or check probably
take rookie seven columns though I'll
put the bishop on c4 yeah bishop on c4
is nice defend everything promise my
King's kind of stuck I play h5 here walk
they came to g6 like the bishop defends
everything everything's defended here I
can just probably flag him but the King
on f5 oh I forgot about that pawn oops
that was unnecessary
I was completely unnecessary play Bishop
b3 planning a 584 and I can still
probably flag him it should be three
again I don't want to repeat one thing I
don't want to do no I don't want to
check my checkmate myself either I can
walk the King it's pretty pad technique
this game but I think it's still looking
good OOP I hung up on again okay but
he's taking this is a losing keep on
ending okay next game do you think if I
win my last friend next week I should
stop going to the club I mean okay keep
the winning streak it's good to be able
to be players below you consistently so
I mean you should stop going if it just
becomes like if you stop learning
basically but if you continue to learn
like if you have interesting games you
can keep going but ultimately it's your
call
what is this opening Bishop f4 so weird
let's play d5 and standings okay I have
a streak but I don't know how many
points I'm getting for the street you
guess I have nine points and then number
seven out of 245 players
it sounds pretty decent I want to play
g5g fives a very thematic move and
somehow we kind of transposed into it
French I don't really play the French
but I know some French ideas on Queen b6
just pressure the pawn looks Pleasant
and this
or the position black can play on both
sides like I have space on the kingside
and I have some pressure
I've pressure all over the place okay I
can take on b2 wait a minute take on
beat two and then like all the spawns
are hanging like all these pawns every
week is rooks hanging yeah this is just
good might be three I think I can take
here because I'm distracting the knight
now I can take the rook I don't think my
Queens getting trapped this might still
attacked it spawns attacks
everything's following our part for
whites we need B to back the only
concern is my queen my queen oh I could
have taken on a 2 I can still take on
you two and black is up a significant
amount of material problem is I need to
get the pieces in the game I want to
play d4 and actually d4 is a fine move
but then 94 could take I can't waste
time here play Bishop d7 develop bishop
comes to e6
he plays rook a1 I have Queen before and
probably the Queen can come back and
things are solid ooh
discoveries oh I'm not really scared
though where is this mic going Queen c7
if necessary can come next even Queen d8
Queen G it might give him significant
problems but I have to keep you side and
defended too
it's going to be patience IPP 6-under -
night when Queen d8 is a plan or I could
do some discovery now I'm threatening
Knight d4 nice discovery I'm also
threatening this pawn kind of a
long-term targets can take black is up
with all the pawns and six pawns to
three pawns and up the exchange take
take take on e5 Wow okay well we're just
trading I'll play Queen g5
oh he's pinning me I could take on f2
and then castle that's kind of funny I
could Castle right away let's take
enough - it's fun line casting with
check I could just go in for the kill
Queen h4 and g3 that looks nice because
when he takes on c6 g3 it's unstoppable
mates life is good
yeah castling really helped out usually
castling is like a defensive move but
it's a very aggressive move in that case
okay next game no time to waste
four out of four currently in sixth
place I'm playing Eric Hansen chess brah
I think he's also streaming let's play
it ready and maybe it'll play Kings
Indian attack yeah I'll play my kind of
cut line or I take before Bishop e7 and
then knight c6 might c6 is kind of the
unusual move but it's playable um I
think I can take again I forget the
theory exactly but remember the idea is
like 94-88 d4 looks playable that's not
on c6 is kind of awkward let's clear up
to you anyway he's gonna play c3 yeah
what to do I want to play c5 Bishop f8
but then Bishop g5 ok I'm just gonna
push the a pawn like when in doubt play
a 5 oh that's scary
IG 5 coming or Bishop g5 coming it could
be brave and play g6 but let's play a 5
a 4 because now rock a5 is a plan I
think maybe he misses and this is kind
of a nasty pin my time management is not
good so far but my rook is good he's
gonna play something like oh actually h4
f we rent it to h6 so that looks
reasonable can i play f5 f5 looks like a
fork it looks weakening but it's a fork
my god I mean you might punish me
somehow oh that was a good move
take take that was a very good move f5
was bad
I can play rook e8 and survive take take
their h6 okay what else to do so this
will take you seven work take you seven
IG v h6 and things are defended sort of
but this structure is very weak maybe
I'll play like 99 s7 trade stuff off but
this rook is attacked to clean e8 defend
the plan is 98 and just start trading
that's a really good position will move
because e fives week you might take on
c6 and 595 or that move also looks
pretty strong I can play this you can
trade bishops if we can just trade
everything and get a quiet position that
would make me happy okay that move
doesn't make me happy
there there taketake maybe h6 doesn't do
anything though b5 maybe there's so much
pressure it seems like he's gonna have
some tactic at some points but if we can
relieve all the crush early I just want
to take on d5 the problem is this is
pinned like this pawn is pinned to the
rook along the e-file so there's so much
x-ray vision here maybe I play rook a6
next just defend stuff that was probably
a good move taketake that's a very good
move I'm getting forked take take
that's unfortunate
then I losing anything the ships
defended
oh I lose the rock oops okay I resign
that was really sad hello a DJ chest dog
good to see you and I only lost three
rating points but now my streak is zero
that's so bad
hello to axe villager long time no see
gotta stay hydrated it's like 90 degrees
outside today it's California weather
it's only springtime in California -
well at least we have a London East six
doesn't move whenever the foal will try
and like defend upon this is actually an
interesting line I have to remember the
theory I think I take in Bishop t7
pretty sure Bishop d7 is a stock fish
move and it's almost a novelty the idea
is to play b6 and I'm not allowing
Bishop b5 that's slightly unexpected b6
is still coming and like this whole
structure is gonna fall apart very soon
for whites hello - Meier 47 I was not a
beast in that that last game
unfortunately unless he's talking he's
talking about the other Eric okay guess
that makes sense
Eric is eric is a beast is referring to
Eric Hanson that not myself Queen okay
I'm gonna play I wanted to play 94
Bishop a4 also a move let's start with
this
I just want to pressure the b4 pawn
bishop take before is coming I don't
think you can defend this maybe he can
I mean 94 it looks really fun let's try
this point a 5 ok that's reasonable I
mean I can still play Queen a5 Bishop b4
and there has to be like a massive
pressure after 92 he has to play rook t1
I can take on eight - maybe at some
point ok how am i winning this I could
just Castle just castle I wanted to take
on b5 but he would take back with Czech
now maybe I can take on b5 this is just
crushing I'm deflecting the Queen from
defending t2 and then I'll take the a to
pawn oh but then he has rook b2
wait a minute I have Knight c3 coming ok
good game I was a decent recovery I'll
lewd 64 so many people have 64 in there
their username she my very first online
account name was chest dude 64 and this
guy's walking into opening prep like
whatever he takes back with queen g4 is
actually kind of annoying for black just
a tricky London line only happens with
this move order dude is not spelled do
ot it was spelled EU de but that's a
nice interesting misspelling I want him
to play 94 so I can made him on g8 but
he's not falling for it ok he wants to
play b5 he's also preventing Knight b5
how can I distract him can i play efore
here before it looks really funny look
like 4
the idea is like want to open the center
when the King still in the center and
this might spin to the d8 square so he's
gonna move his Queen probably Queen b6
and I don't know if I'm even that much
I'll probably just have to complete
developments like Knight f3 okay he
wants to trade stuff hmm I don't want to
trade
I could retreat I play Knight g5 Knight
g5 looks overly ambitious but it has a
point like he can't play h6 with the
media threats because the H plans pins
in the meantime I want to play 95 and
target at 7 rook h7 hangs something
maybe we don't trade Queens yeah let's
keep Queens on the board rook HSN what
does that move
ok I'm gonna develop and then 95 is
coming OC 7 was hanging groups pleading
forgot about c7 Bishop g6 looks like a
fun move I don't know if it does
anything though but the rook in the
center I really want to play Bishop g6
but he just takes on e5 kinda look like
c3 just solid ok now Bishop g6 is a move
because he can't take it because he gets
forked and f7 can't be defended
and now everything falls apart oh that's
nice
okay nice game back on the streak
playing a decent player gaining some
rating points I haven't played chest
lock on glitz in a long time so I think
my rating is slightly like provisional
now C for this is I think considered to
vyas but actually I think as far as if
this is white I think this is playable
yeah this is definitely a line I know II
5 is supposed to be played at some
points just play it right away
Bishop deep - interesting
the problem is I don't really have too
much experience in this structure
I assume the bishop should be on d4 like
if he plays before Bishop g4 it's a good
Bishop I'm also slowing down at 4 play a
5 positional move preventing expansion
maybe ideas of a for g5 is also
interesting move do you find we take a
bunch of things gonna play faster let's
play rook b8 just preventing before
might be typical for him to play Knight
a4 I'm ready to play Bishop d4 and then
maybe I'll play c5 or maybe not what did
you take and then d5 maybe you only live
once
d5 we take oh7 could hang and so I would
take a queen looks playable and I'm
making him think
sometimes in blitz you just want to make
your opponent think and then flag them
okay Knights c5 interesting I mean I
want to play Knight g4 and Queen h4 but
he has h3 I develop the bishop
Bishop g4 it looks slightly pointless
like the bishop doesn't seem to be doing
that much but the plan is bishop here
and then eventually Bishop g6 where does
the Queen go Queen c6 I guess
then there's tactics it's kind of
annoying Queen doesn't have too many
squares here it's quitting d6 I still
want to do this maneuver let's take and
then Queen g7 may be threatening bishop
at five not sure where he's going to put
the rook
maybe he'll play rugby c1
mmm
Bishop t3 I forgot about that move g6g
six looks weakening but it has its
purpose as Bishop f5 is kind of hard to
stop now unless he moves the Queen
but where does he move the Queen the
Queen has no square is accept you won
the my ugly side bishop take F to wait I
should take up to Queen take F to he's
writing f7 I mean this can't be good for
whites maybe e4 hmm no play here
now I'm threatening bishop egg f2 and if
he moves the bishop to e4 Bishop c4 okay
so that's reasonable
take take okay let's move the rook
somewhere more useful
hello 2x I sparks how's it going okay
I got to get the time advantage to
that's most important my positions nice
the time would be nicer let's do this Oh
is rook do you want to move rook to you
one queen bee to still had pressure
before is weak I could go after before I
could go after stuff on the Kings side
too and I had the time advantage X I
sparks I'm doing well I'm just very very
busy a lot of stuff happening
okay this position needs my full focus
maybe I want to take I don't want to
take as as bishop is awkward like the
bishop side down to the pawn well I
could take and play Bishop d3 I wouldn't
exchange oh I know in an exchange rook
before but then Queen c2 okay this
should be good enough he's defending the
pawn
mmm
sneaky move this might just be winning
you can't stop work everyone that's nice
I was unexpected too it's just game over
Wow that ended kind of abruptly I mean I
had the constant pressure and time
advantage so sometimes in cases like
that it just just leads to good things
okay
another London Brenden bread-and-butter
opening he plays c6 let's play 92 and
we're gonna go into this usual line
Queen b6 I've had so many games like
this let's play before threatening b5
already Rick see it's the best move here
ooh
well he's threatening Knight h5 so I'll
start with h3 mm-hmm okay now I can play
this this Bishop is always controlling
b8 so when we trade pawns in the V file
opens he can't get the rook to b8 a very
important factor in the position so one
of the main ideas for black is to play
e5 which might come pretty soon Oh
what pun to take it probably doesn't
matter playing out of three
so I'm discouraging me five and at some
point I want to win a pawn start slowly
Bishop e2 I'm fine with taking we could
trade or we or I could play King
Eike Castle or play King z2 here he
wants to take him play e5 just a little
bit annoying
what to do there's not very high rated
okay I'm gonna play this I think the
king should help out on the the Queen
side so II fight happens we could trade
everything taketake oh he wins g2 in the
end that looks okay because his pawns
are fixed on light squares because c6
pawn is going to be weak and we're just
trading the position does transform
though question is do I play rook g1 or
rook h2 after Bishop take G - oh he's
going for immediate attack interesting
King c3 to be a little bit careful I
don't think he should have allowed f3
though oh he wants to play rook b3 ah I
forgot about that move oops
it's still equal material but he has a
lot of pressure here oh this is not what
I wanted yeah that was bad
this is going to take some some survival
skills this is really bad okay let's
play King f2 I'm walking into Bishop d3
but didn't really see what else to do
he's going for the pawn promotion okay I
can live with that because my work will
be on a1 then my king will walk back
hopefully well now I have Bishop do you
want bishop d one's a nice move because
he's still down upon rights or can I not
count I can't count it's equal material
but maybe we'll trade stuff uh-oh wait
tick tick oh the endgame is losing for
me I have to play King B - that's very
unpleasant he's gonna win G - this is
bad
I really butchered this h4 maybe h4
there there there okay only chance
I gotta somehow flagon but that's
difficult down to ponds and down on time
thanks for the follow whoever you are I
see the notification but I can't I don't
have time to read the name this is sad
this is really sad
maybe I can cut them off though and then
start pre moving
hey I won I flagged him that was
unexpected oh man the endgame technique
well that's a relief
hello - mini anti taco on UNPO I'm doing
well today how are you okay let's play
it let's put you for play more
aggressively play Grand Prix mmm this is
a real Grand Prix one of my favorite
openings unfortunately a ex villager we
can't play the Scotch against a Sicilian
I'll keep it in mind to play of scotch
in future games but this is a great
what's opening Grand Prix because ideas
like are so natural even going into the
middle game like this we'll need rich
attacking ideas start with Queen g3
Queen h3 f5 maybe g4 g5
I've always wanted to be good at this
game but I haven't put in the time um
yeah you have to put in the time to be
good than anything really you have to
put in time and the way to do that is
either through discipline or through
passion like find ways to enjoy it and
then putting in the time is something
that you'll want to do I'm happy with
this position my g4 g5 is coming and
black doesn't have too many I can
mediate ideas just gonna pawn storm
maybe even drop the Queen well now I'm
not chopping the Queen let's start with
this I can play h4 next and then we can
connect for I haven't checked the
standings but I'm in fifth place it
looks like I have a streak of four games
yeah this is a very much old earning
experience for me I can play e5 here and
then d5 and his bishop is sad I mean my
bishops kind of sad too if you play a C
for both our bishops are pretty
depressed the nice thing is that I mean
the attack is gonna come so quickly on
the Kings side we can take now this
bishop is happy because I play c3 and
Bishop e1 I think his best chance was to
play c4 there but okay there are so many
attacking ideas combined by combining f5
and Bishop e1 and H for this should be
over very soon what to do Bishop g5
maybe okay let's start with Bishop e1
you have six possibilities
okay we can trade off the rooks I think
I just want to pawn that in that
sequence or okay three is kind of
annoying I'm looking at f6g take out six
and Queen h4 Dean is my g6
Bishop g5 what to do visually it looks
amazing I'm gonna play rook c1 it's an
open file maybe it's the wrong idea that
looks reasonable taketake okay I mean
let's just trade off rooks cuz his rook
is annoying me
ooh did I miss something
tick okay I can take he won the pawn
deck I want to have tactics against his
queen
oh this is nice this should take h7 and
he can't take because my g5 wins the
Queen and now I think Queen h3 should be
crushing he has one check on a one then
King g2
hmm I'm not actually threatening mate
here but something should work out I
would think what is that move the
strange now I can play Bishop see to
check I'm just gonna play Bishop t2
because I don't see what he's doing okay
good game next game I have a streak of
five I'm playing this guy again I think
I beat earlier
I forgot how I beat him but pretty sure
I won we have a perk at three I guess
very early Queen side expansion wants to
play e5 what to do Bishop e3 development
is kind of awkward for whites but I'm
gonna try and find some harmony like
play Knight g3 and then then the King
side can develop and maybe combine it
with like h4 h5 yeah this looks Pleasant
ooh
h5 very ambitious so if I play g5 he
plays h4 okay that can't be too bad cuz
I have this move but now I'm kind of
stuck again it was very strange opening
maybe 91 thank you for the follow the
fail gamers appreciate that okay I'm
just gonna develop
it's not that easy to attack on the
kingside it's like things are pretty
closed down but h4 could be a potential
weakness and later he doesn't
necessarily want to castle
bring the rook away from h8 e 5 is
interesting because g5 could be hanging
in some lines maybe c3 I still want to
develop like 92 oh that was probably a
good move cuz I'm losing g5 but do I
care I don't care too much
well have her cheat one at four is kind
of weak it doesn't feel like I'm down
upon my center is pretty beautiful Queen
d2 coming and night b3 there's some cop
here 95 maybe well I could take no I
can't take on that floor taking on that
forward could be a future idea somehow
exploiting the G file what to do work b1
may be so weird position like both of us
don't want to commit to castling a Queen
h4 looks like it's coming let's play
this I think my king is relatively safe
in the center let's play Knight d7
pretty exotic move but I will just hide
target d6 he defends a for maybe a for
doesn't really do much b5 I don't want
to commit to okay I'll move back
mm enough to coming I don't want to
trade Queens but it makes a position
easier to play my king will probably is
land on d2 and I have to play quicker
hmm take tick okay let's bring the
knight back someday I want to play a
four start with my c5 I don't think I'm
scared of him taking oh maybe I am cuz
he's a knight a four in the end that was
a mistake but I'll try and make things
complicated okay he doesn't take that's
good
take take bring this other Knight to b3
time situation is not that great though
kingi to getting off the D file but I'm
losing upon this is bad so now I'm down
to pawns but it's still a playable
position just have to keep things
complicated
maybe I win the H pawn my King on e 2 is
relatively safe and this nice good on b3
covering d2 maybe I'll play rook to you
one next oh that was a good move I
forgot about that
ouch I wish it a hyung looks so ugly but
wrote G to Bishop c5 doesn't kill me I
got a little quick got a flag this guy
or girl wgm Leslie so draw yeah
it's a draw do I get points for drawing
31 points number seven oh that's
unfortunate
okay I have the time advantage too maybe
I shouldn't have treated rooks okay what
to do
new game 96 happens
hey we have a scotch hopefully X
villager is still here and he's happy
let's do wait what's the move here 906
906 we're going into this line this is
not a typical scotch
I'd actually transposed to a to nights
whatever we call this um maybe f5 I
don't know too much Theory here I know
f5 s one idea now that I file is open
one Bishop d6 will probably come and c5
this looks Pleasant I have pieces to
attack with
so there's 63 minutes left that's a long
time lot can change in 63 minutes Bishop
g4 enticing I just want to build up
pressure I have almost all my pieces
with potential to attack on the kingside
hello to evh good to see you
I think there's far less people at least
in the chats than than normally so it's
a nice nice and small crowd today bishop
g6 whoa okay g4 is just so weakening
he's trying to be aggressive though
maybe I have to take yeah I'm gonna take
and play Queen d6
and now there's the threat against
Zurich there's also a threat of 94 so
move like Queen e2 just runs into 94 and
as rookies traps I think okay so that's
reasonable rook f3 kingi - mmm build up
pressure first there's a few weaknesses
to exploit now I think rekha rook f3 is
good I wanted to follow up with Bishop
g4 the problem was he had ripped a key
for in that other line but now after
King g2 Bishop a4 I think it's just
crushing Tom O'Leary
why can't you join the cash arena can
you late join I'm not entirely sure I'm
pretty sure you can late join but I
don't know I know very little bit about
how this tournament works all I know is
how to play chess okay I'm gonna play
Queen here attacking the knight
attacking this pawn this pawn is still
hanging
[Music]
we can take on F 297 should be okay so
late joint is possible that's cool
it's like title Tuesday I think they
join us impossible I have to take with
pawn oh so I have okay
I didn't realize this but I can see like
the number of points everyone has so I
have 31 points Eric Hanson has 37 points
I'm not too far away from him and he
lost the streak that's good I still
don't know how the point system works
like if you're on a streak how does that
how does it give you more points just
having a streak of nine give you more
points if you win or is it like a chess
where you you can only win like a
maximum of points if you're on a streak
I just want to like finish this off g5 I
don't see in the media mate he's about
to flag bring the Queen back target h3
is being in the link we can trade
everything it's a winning King pawn
ending like like Katrina or I could like
pre move multiple moves in a row maybe
that would be useful in some cases
bertoldo pal weary hello oh he's doing
something why aren't you playing for
cash on me chess isn't that easier on
chest easier than chess calm um tomorrow
there's a very big event on me chess
it's a titled arena with a first-place
prize of over two thousand dollars which
I think Magnus Carlsen is playing and so
I'll definitely be there for that I'm
not actually playing in it I was asked
by HS admins to do the official stream
so I'll be giving commentary for like
two to three hours however long that
event runs so that should be cool yeah
for the regular viewer is usually ice
cream on me chest but in a streaming
tournament like this on chess calm I
mean how can you resist
so okay Bishop d3 it's a slightly
unusual setup with white cast and Queen
side but I enjoy positions like this in
blitz this is easy to play always play
King me one and now there is some idea
of attacking on the Kings side start
with d5 if he takes a few tries still
win a pawn on d5 I have a Bishop h7 in
the very end so maybe you'll play e5 not
expecting that but if I can take and
it's weakening take two
let's do it something should be good
maybe I'll bring the knight to g6
so yeah I'm expecting a lot more viewers
tomorrow than today I haven't even
checked of your account
Wow 29 viewers well hello to all 29 of
you if you haven't said hello in the
chat feel free to do so there's any new
viewers out there welcome
I haven't streamed too recently but I'm
planning the stream more this coming
week this should be forced mate somehow
maybe not
eh 896 should be some kind of like
window okay he resigns next game hello
Daniel Moreno good to see you it's going
well
on a streak streak of two games only
okay let's play you for it some more
efore games and play this French line I
guess 29 viewers isn't bad giving that
like so many other people are streaming
and we have a rubenstein French which
I'm completely fine with oh we can take
on f6 half the time I play this black
gets the Queen trapped on f6 like white
wants to play Bishop to e3 in Bishop g5
so he knows he knows to play h6 okay now
the other plan for why this stood is
Castle queenside an attack on the Kings
side or attack in the center like look
at this development black is playing
like so slowly to the bow of his pieces
I'm the queenside castle and everything
will be developed a knight c6 is a good
move I should probably retreat and the
Queen I need seven is this so so awkward
Castle queenside Queen on d6 is still
awkward okay you wants to play b5 just
put the put everything in the center
good things should happen at some point
95 maybe Queen e3 is a move look like we
need to the saldo move now there's a bit
more pressure on his Queen and now I'll
play 95 I just want to like open up some
lines in the center I have ideas of f4
f5 though Queen a fives likely to happen
Bishop d6 okay now I think is their
tactics take take Bishop b5 he can take
with Bishop on b5 this doesn't look
right
okay I'm gonna take and play queen g4
felt like there should have been
something better than just didn't see it
I mean I still have a lot of pressure
this is queen g7 Ponton is currently
hanging castles Queen side somehow he
escaped this can take on g7 though it
should be up a pawn because f7 is
hanging Queen c3 comes with check if he
plays Ritchie eights now the idea is if
he takes one F 2 I have rook F 1 when I
win F 7
question is how do I make use of this
like battery probably Queenie 500 but
then Queen take G 3.86 work c7
immediately probably doesn't meet too
much yeah this is trickier than I
thought I'm gonna be up a pawn after
taking any six I can take on h6 should
be enough to win
okay he's attacking me I have Queen b6
here looks reasonable this king is far
less safe than my king now he's
defending b7 with his queen at Queen c7
[Music]
I should just play quietly like 83 I
gotta move quicker I figure out about
time he takes on d3 I probably take with
Brooke still have the extra pawn a
tricky move but now we're just trading
still up a pawn
I'll get the time advantage and then
I'll Fagin or I'll just convert the
endgame rook should probably stay where
does it recline and go probably on f3
never mind
d7 the king will come in my king will
come to c3 just like on needs to fix
their arrows because when I draw the
arrow from a2 to c3 the King doesn't
move like a nice let's do this very nice
[Music]
the D pawn is a passed pawn okay next
game doc Holly thanks for streaming
first time watching it live oh wow
usually watch my lectures on call at the
hospital are you sick or are you a
doctor huh
thanks for the message though appreciate
that comment oh he's okay
you're probably a doctor if you're on
call great and asking an odd question if
people were to play guess some of the
top layers you recommend look at the
games with openings you play or the
opposite wait what's yeah look at like
if you're gonna practice with guests and
move look at games where
a strong player played your opening in
one because then you you not only
practice over them you practice the
middlegame structures I come from the
opening and just all around you can
focus on many different areas we have
some kind of weird open Sicilian
I actually don't know any theory in this
line but it looks decent maybe I'd keep
the bishop on this diagonal this Bishop
is really annoying and even Queen b6
here was prophylaxis against Bishop III
and while I'm doing I'm just trying to
prevent him from castling kingside
because if he castles Queen side I'm
ready to attack though maybe uh maybe
that's the best option for him when the
attack isn't that simple a4 b4
oh yes Knight e5 triki triki 95 maybe 4
is a good move what to do
wait maybe 90 thoughts not that bad
because I can just take it with a pawn
ok you plays a five Wow it's interesting
do 95 probably Justin this is a piece
here so maybe he'll play Knight a 492
logical and take on e5 but let me trade
we play 94
and we might be trading off the pawns
but I like the fact that his King is
still in the center cuz if I win B -
there's like c3 weaknesses and he might
just play rook b1 here than a 5 things I
didn't know I should be looking at yeah
I mean really any sort of game is a
value I like to look at miniatures like
look at quick games where one player had
an attack but it depends what you want
to practice okay let's take here so we
trade and you still can't castle I mean
I can't castle either really I still
have to develop I know six is coming
next
I'm 4x er likes to see me play the
London yeah I'll play more London's I've
been playing easy for in recent games
it's against lower rate the players I
found efore is a quicker way to try and
win so he would like to play Bishop III
but it would hang a 5
well maybe it's complicated because my
bishop will also be attacked okay what's
going on here I can take on e4 and just
went up on I think the lines work out
so I can take on d3 intermediate move
and he still can't castle that's great
and I went up on and all his stuff is
weak ooh that move but I can take his
rip in the end he's not even winning
like the knight back as his Knights
attacked so now blacks up a rook but he
can finally castle okay King f2 so let's
just convert this up a full Brooke
life is good that six coming just want
to open files promised rooks aren't
effective if there's no clean files
ooh this is gonna be mate okay next game
no time to waste
I have a streak of four I'm in sixth
place
rocky zero - wait this guy looks really
familiar
I click on this profile in just a moment
so we have an elephant Sicilian I've
played hundreds of games in this line
eventually we'll get some iqp position
he'll play Bishop III most likely
forcing me to take play Knight c3 Queen
b6 and really the game starts around
like move 15 after we both developed ok
developments pretty smooth okay maybe I
can start thinking maybe Knight a 5
logical move these squares could be
exploitable 95 logical oh he wants to
play Bishop f4 interesting
maybe 95 here queen h5 g6
I'll play g6 immediately it looks
weakening but it kills this Bishop h4 so
aggressive play h5 wow what to do don't
always like it when people attack me I
t5 h5 come on upon their a pawns upon
well he's attacking me more
ok let's defend a scary position a lot
of firepower on the King side during the
night towards the center can't be a bad
thing unless he just mates me
immediately this is scary
I feel pretty scared he has so many
pieces ok I could take nineth for all
things are crazy I have to go for the
counter-attack go take on e5 first maybe
that's not a bad thing that s6 is gonna
be very weak though I could take his
knight in the end nice oh he has 9 of 6
first no maybe it's not that bad though
ohh
maybe it is that bad this is looking
really bad how did that happen
I have 500 you starting to win the Queen
to 8 maybe what else to do and my time
situations just awful
King jeans ok I'm happy with a draw
night here I guess
oh he's gonna take though that's bad wow
it's been a while since I've lost that
badly take here maybe I'm not losing yet
still make him work for it here this is
really bad that was a good move
Oh a nice 24:40 out well maybe he'll
mate he'll hang made on g2 please
I don't know why I'm playing the song
but I mean I'm threatening Nathan one so
all it takes is one bad move okay now I
can resign what happened to Lee chess I
still lovely chess I'm streaming there
tomorrow I'm just playing a streamer
cash tournament chess calm and saliyah
so probably a returning viewer and Neil
flatfoot believing in me I appreciate
that
okay inter master 2017 let's come back
here we'll play a time on on trying
recover I don't think I've had a
mainline time on of yet 95 this guy
destroyed Eric Hanson okay hopefully he
doesn't destroy Eric Rosen b5 um another
aggressive player there should be seven
oh maybe I should have played I should
have played d6 first I forgot line
opening nuances so Knight h5 I'm gonna
try and slow him down
ideally I should have played d6 Knight f
d7 was bad move order it's not a good
start Bradon asking more questions I
can't look at the question now maybe
after this game because I'm under very
bad pressure but I do have two bishops
he's a pretty scary pawn storm Bishop c5
I would like to make use of this f4
square somehow like maybe e5 at some
points
okay that was unexpected maybe that's a
good move
tick tick it's probably a very good move
I'm feeling the pain take take - this is
bad
it's d7 hangs okay let's try and make
the most of this position this is so bad
though like what do I do
Castle queenside
probably just resigned Wow some pretty
painful games back to back but you
should never give up hope
oh you wants to play f6 now six is
killer I think what do I do here it's
just no hope age six maybe take you Oh
Queen e7 ouch okay I resign
that was pretty brutal resign that's why
I'm looking forward to tomorrow I don't
have to play chess tomorrow I just have
to commentates tomorrow is probably just
watching Magnus Carlson's games it's
gonna be fun hello - Nick up I don't
know if I said hi but I'm sorry you have
to see such graphic games let's play c4
let's change things up a little bit now
I have to move quicker I play the slime
some kind of an Oni but no knee with III
like a c5 is playable 92 typical move
did he just hang upon maybe it's a
sacrifice but it looks like a free pawn
seems like he's just playing fast but
okay I'm up upon now I'll have some King
side attack I'll live with it maybe f4
I'm gonna start with Murphy 1 and then
b4
really this guy just has no respect for
me it's face flying so fast Knight g4 is
a good move he wants to play visit f6
also has ideas of targeting this Knights
scary line but I think this is okay
my queen can go to f3 it's still scary
we need for maybe a queen still scary
Queenie for and the queen doesn't want
to be on you for a night wants to be on
you for that's a bit awkward but maybe
I'll play Queen c2 at some points take
take take this might be okay I was just
playing so quickly it's so scary he
wants to play Bishop f5 surviving up a
couple pawns defending h3 I just want to
play 20 g5 just trade Queens the time
situation is not good
[Music]
take I guess opposite colored bishops
how many pawns am i up should be up
enough yeah we're in the trade this
might just be a draw but now he has to
trade actually maybe yeah still push for
a win
oh no I hung a bishop no please like 45
no oh carelessness maybe he'll forget
about that five so there's still hope
here that was so bad though so bad
there's still hope
Barack Obama at six coming
I didn't calculate this but I'm hoping
it works oh my queen with check yes
okay now pre moving time somehow this is
working out
yes I somehow won that after wandering a
bishop yay okay I have a streak of one
game yeah it would have been painful to
lose two games in a row and that that
attack was scary like he was moving so
fast and he almost beat me playing this
guy again man this was just non-stop
chess okay we have a veresov type gambit
I actually studied some theory here
let's move c6 is kind of sneaky the idea
is if he takes I play e5 if he doesn't
take actually don't know what to do
maybe Bishop here should just be up upon
maybe we're just trading he'll take on
e4 or not this looks Pleasant cuz I'm up
a pawn and he's severely overextended h6
is maybe strong
I'd use of Queen h4 I'll play Queen a5
try and attack from both directions
this is his King as know we're safe to
go in the center it's gonna get harassed
on either side of the board's gonna get
attacked the g6 is nice I'm threatening
Bishop g3 maybe he missed when I 5
happens wait how am i meeting him am i
meeting him I would like to meet him
kingi - let's start with this move
I'm just attacking h4 pawn
doing defensive stuff yeah I might just
have to bring more pieces into the
action and like develop the Knights
because he's still kind of stuck I'm
fine with this council queen side so I
looked at Queen a5 in Bishop f3 but I
thought after King G - he's just
controlling f3 enough times maybe I
missed something though ok we could
trade Queens or we could not trade
Queens I just want to bring a rope to
the G foul he wants to make things
complicated but the opening of the D
file should play in my favor
hopefully kids do this
my bishops are so strong
Queen e5 coming
queen up chicks coming oh no I didn't
want to play f6 I wanted to play Queen
f6 what is f6
so knowing Mouse slip was more of a
trackpad slip ok c5 should kill him
because there's a pin tricky move I can
take this so she has no checks and I'm
attacking the Queen
so we'll probably play Queen a3 but okay
mm I have to defend a little bit here
I'll run my king
oh he is rook d7 though oops that was
unnecessary that was completely
unnecessary
yeah let's not lose this it's such a
good position I just got completely
careless who f6 happens okay
f6 was just such a bad move play this
check he's playing passively which is
good there should be 5 will come rook g8
is like mating Oh where's my mate
such bad quality chess here rook g8 oh
I'm not even threatening mates
I just want to somehow
now I'm threatening made him two or
three or four right Chuck I'm one check
you should have played King do you one
but he Flags okay bad game I'm moving on
Z Fox with the line Queen f5 King G to
Bishop f3 tick tick tick
oh I had some discovery oops okay
killer mania let's play let's play a
dragon a3 okay I'll play g6 let's play
this I think this is playable because I
actually never mind okay we'll have some
like close Sicilian dragon type setup I
always play h5 I gotta play much quicker
that's my one defect like streaming and
playing blitz I just played you slowly
maybe I'll Castle queenside here try and
like target the kingside weaknesses see
just allow f6 I think he just a lot of
six and he's trying to play it off cool
but I'm just up at Bishop things were
falling apart I think that's gonna get a
king-size attack now let's see heap
sacking 95 is a decent move
okay put blocks just up a rook Queen
takes pawn why not so I want to attack
to my Queen h4 Bishop g4 some attacking
resources I'm okay with this line
oh I'm not okay with that line I just
lost a queen if you're like the longer
this tournament go is a like
lower-quality the chest becomes it's
such a bad game Wow okay
I have to fight back Bishop e5 or Bishop
take B - maybe to start with like went
up Hall in line that's I'll put the
bishop on f6 the material situation
isn't that bad it's just my king this a
bit unsafe wants to play 96 good move
scary position
yeah not the most pleasant situation
here cuz 96 is a major threat a 5 is
hanging the humor just taking on a 7
I'll do it I've now two minors for the
Queen but at least I keep the bishop
pair and this bishop so strong the
bishop he can't play Bishop d5 I won't
think I want to get the rook to the G
file it might be slow though
but if I can play like King King d7
maybe and rook f8 his rooks gonna come
to e1 maybe I go for like H 4 H 3 hmm
this pawn is falling this is pretty
unfortunate and my time my precious time
take-take-take
okay I don't think he can defend g2 so
maybe that's my one hope oh never mind
he's just counter to the king Oh such a
bad game I was up earlier too
what happens just getting tired okay I
just hung in the more material oh I
wanted to offer a draw but he just
missed that he could take my rook
I didn't mean to offer a diamond to
resign but let's try and push pawns
miracles do happen because there's still
some mating ideas against this king
if he plays a Ron pre-move okay I resign
next game I was really sad
oh I'm playing a GM GM Creek or let's
play a London who is this guy we should
have for this guy is from Brazil never
heard of him play III somewhat trendy
line might be five
I think this line is supposed to be
pleasant for whites okay play this move
I can play that move like an Blitz um
I'm fine with this
like just sack the exchange get some
King side attack Oh Braden was asking a
question earlier I don't know if I
responded going to study with some games
okay see ya Braden if you have a
question just send me a private message
Precor has won several Kings arena
tournaments I'll have to take him down I
mean this is my first ever Kings arena
tournament okay I'm trying to provoke h6
so now there's some target to attack
okay g6 is weak v96 is coming h6 is also
kind of aim
this looks like a pleasant position I'll
try and avenge Daniel Moreno for Treecko
wrecking him I mean this could be
wreckage very soon for black this rooks
are useless here my minor pieces are
good i t6 is coming can Castle queenside
if necessary
let's start by casting Queen side 95 on
the horizon question is does 96 do
anything it's a decent square I would
like to play a 95 that's got to be fine
especially if he has to trade off this
dark square Bishop because now my my
darts for Bishop is just a monster on e5
and he's gonna have issues especially if
I can like rook lifts he wants to trade
nights I could win b7 that opens files
for the rooks
now let's just trade I'm okay with this
I want to play G for next open the G
file get the rook to d1 f4 should be
fine
maybe he'll play queen g4 but then h6
hangs know the Queen's tied down to h6
so he's going for the Queen trade I
still want to play G for Queen h5 I can
hop in
g6 is attacked B sevens attacked he
defends think about playing GM's like
this they put up resistance take some
extra effort to convert but okay the
positions so good let's prepare g4
idea is g4 pawn to g4 than Queen e2 so
he's getting ready for that so maybe I
play Queen c2 still preparing g4 and if
I don't beat him in the position I'll
beat him on time I think that's the plan
put the rook attacking the pawn let's
defend with the King looks wrong but I
want to play Queen b3 he actually has no
way to exploit the King like h8 is
off-limits
I'm gonna infiltrate Queen d6 coming and
his queen is actually either player to
defend so he's gonna cocoon um this
should just be over somehow I can take
upon take a few ponds
ship here let's push up on first way I
should move a bit quicker
I put the palm in e6 make sure it's
defended maybe put the Queen on be
something oops
not the most impressive time scramble
well I have to be careful now what's
going on hey he flagged okay
I was almost falling apart I think you
had repetition between g3 there but most
of that game was good for the most parts
I have a streak of one I have 51 points
I'm in 14th place there's only 13
minutes left which only means probably
just a few games left we'll play another
Grand Prix attack
oh this is kind of annoying actually see
if he plays Knight g4 I have to play
Brooke d2 but it's still okay
he traded off his light squared bishop
so this bishop is slightly more powerful
if he gives me a chance I'll play h3 he
wants to play b5 let's play before a
five positional Oh what does that move
what to do here let's just go for f5
very thematic break open up some lines I
didn't even see that pawn was hanging I
guess that's a free pawn but I don't
really care about the the Queen side I
care about the King side so now there's
some idea is like taking on g6
repositioned the Queen to g3 nice moves
back use being calm keep the plot
attention I'll play Bishop g5 ideas of
Queen III Queen h3 and maybe push up h6
at some points put the bishop back on b3
so who's leading Oh Eric Hansen of
course oh I got fort what happens just
not paying attention it's not the end of
the world I should still win this is
still a nice attack but that was not
necessary I mean on the bright side he
had to trade off his night which is
maybe a key defender in these sort of
situations I'm gonna build up pressure
on f7 now this is probably a major
threat after take g6 which I don't think
he defended against I mean what to do
here is that sevens attack three times
four times actually only defended twice
ok reasonable yeah you six was the best
move I can take here now
maybe I'll go for Bishop f6
I'm expecting King h8 replace King
taking h7 so there's some discussion
about where the bishop should go in
Grand Prix I mean usually the common
squares are Bishop c4 Bishop b5 yeah
this should be over maybe it was a
blessing in disguise that I got Forks
just led to a quicker attack oh how do I
finish this maybe rook h6 okay next game
maybe time for one more game
hey I'm cutting Creek Oregon let's try
and beat them again I'll play a dragon
or a tie - it's considering playing the
dragon g3 I'll play my pet line I don't
think this is a great line but it's not
bad triplets h4
I'm trying to play quickly I'm actually
out of theory but all these moves look
reasonable put the night on you five tap
on the Queen then maybe I'll like take
on e3 and play Knight c4 or maybe b5
first just preparing like c4 keeping the
tension making him think because the
last game I beat him he took way too
much time like early in the game and
then I just had to flag him
so Knight c4 here looks nice
ooh we could trade yeah we could trade
then I have a 5 and his Bishop is dead
maybe just Bishop e6 there's a v6 or
Bishop e7 or King e7 so many choices
let's play this the centralizing move if
he plays that for a very important move
f6
I completely forgot about b3 that was
unnecessary
mmm that was bad now I'm just losing a
pawn I must do I have before here wait a
minute
oh that's not good and play before and
try and confuse him I forgot b3 was a
threat maybe I wouldn't see to in some
position this d4 square for the knight
is uh is a very real possibility
yeah that's annoying
King off 60s f4 but maybe that's still
okay as we can trade off rooks
open the knees g5 so if he plays I for
maybe I take and then put the King on e5
that's scary I mean I don't see the
killer blow here but it looks very scary
because now the bishop is very active
piece but I do have 93 coming there's no
clear check that he can deliver now he's
threatening what is he threatening 93
maybe 93 King G floor I don't know
what's going on this is crazy I mean
somehow black is up to pot ins the
things kind of turned around prevent
Knight e3 you can start winning pawns
back let's reinforce everything with
this move but my time situation is not
good active rook double attack actually
let's bring the other rook in rook d2
could be a problem for him it's probably
gonna be another time scramble the
knight can come to e4 which is not the
most pleasant thing for me what to do
maybe just f6 Knight c3 coming wait I
have this move rook there f6 okay gotta
move quicker expecting rook b5
I mean maybe Knight c3 will come - can I
Rick should go to C - I think I'm
getting mated just have to move quickly
I'll be able to trade off something with
a bishop on d5 but the rooks on the
second Oh what am i threatening that has
a knight should have gone to you for not
the bishop now he realizes that no I get
forked okay it's okay
not just faction in this position hey I
want another game to know against that
guy having trouble against the weaker
players for the against the gions life
is good
Daniel Moreno asking for recommendations
for learning the tirage defense in the
French as wait wait the tirage defense
you mean just the tirage against the
French as white look at the games of
Michael Adams because he consistently
plays efore and he's pretty
knowledgeable in tirage just type in
like Michael Adams French you know find
a bunch of trash games so there's only
two minutes left I actually don't know
like if two minutes go by and we're
still playing does the game still count
for the tournament I would guess not but
maybe
looks like I'll finish in top ten I
actually don't know the price structure
should probably figure that out east six
take-take-take let's play this the
Lockean gambits la fille and gambits a
surprise opening but it's not like an
opening you should play long-term but
it's not a bad like thing to have in
your repertoire it just for looks
especially against lesser experienced
players so the H files of a friend I'm
gonna try and make use of this somehow
Queen d2 threatening Maiden to rook h8
is normal on Castle queenside when the
time runs out all games finish really do
they end just abruptly or we get do we
get to finish I mean we should be able
to finish the game like at least 4
rating points I'll try and play quicker
here to take some risk mmm I can't take
that let's do this some attack Queen e7
they end immediately what is that that's
bogus so what's what's the result then
okay please resign I'm just up at night
there's six seconds left though just
resign no I also might back that's
annoying I mean we should at least
finish the game okay well good
tournament I guess that was a new
experience
I finished top ten I played 23 games
what does this mean no people can't see
what I'm looking at but if I do this
then people can see what I'm looking at
so it says 58 so I assume that's my
score but then when I hover over it it
says eighteen point five
of 23 did I actually play 23 games maybe
I did and the highest scoring player was
Erik Hansen was 75 points interesting
okay that was a new experience I guess
maybe I can keep going yeah it's it's
different from Lee Chester I guess in a
few ways I'm gonna find the Kings arena
page what Kings arena just find the
announcements I'm just curious about the
price structure oh there's only top
three places top and view title player
that's probably Eric Hanson that's
unfortunate
winner of the Twitter poll can't be the
same person as a buff okay well maybe I
have a chance for that that's performing
not titled player yeah okay interesting
well that was cool
it wasn't my main intention to win a
prize it was just my main goal to like
finish the tournament and do a somewhat
watchable stream so I hope people enjoy
that I might be back tonight for like
just another another stream tomorrow is
a big day tomorrow is the Lee chest
titled arena it's gonna be probably a
more more viewed tournament than this am
I allowed to go to Lee chess from the
stream I think I am because I'm not like
a partner
so let's switch over to Lee chess though
but the thing is kind of messed up oh
thank you see Nation chess for
subscribing but just to share with
everyone tomorrow if your title player
you should play this there's over a
hundred there is 136 title players sign
signed up I'm pretty sure Magnus Carlsen
is going to join
he's played the last three events it's a
two-hour bullet tournament and I'm doing
official commentary for it well if
people can see that but you can you can
watch my commentary I'm sure other
players will be streaming to crew 60 for
hosting me with 11 viewers appreciate
that from 364 Wow maybe I should keep
the stream going wow this is so weird
I'm using leech s going back and forth
between leech s and chess calm well I'm
trying to make everyone happy
I appreciate the sub from M singer for
two months in a row and znation chests
six months in a row he's probably the
most loyal subscriber I really
appreciate that
yeah I will most likely be back tonight
because I want to test the I want to
test the stream on me chest I'm gonna
change the format just to make sure I
can do like commentary smoothie tomorrow
appreciate the follow from GTX gaming 23
yeah you finally get to meet me yeah for
any new viewers let me know where you're
from because sometimes I
I'm not true like what the best time is
to stream I'm currently in California so
I'm out in Pacific time so I'll probably
be back around 10:00 or 11:00 p.m.
tonight
just do a quick stream maybe do a crew
64 match if he's back to mo - man I do
have a schedule but currently there's
very few things on it because I am I'm
just so busy with traveling it's hard to
plan ahead like even a few days so this
coming week I'll be more flexible I'll
probably put together a more set
schedule for this week once I figure out
my free time oh geez Chuck's gaming is
from California as well interesting and
physical appearance is exactly like you
wait what he looks like my twin brother
interesting I've been compared to a lot
of different
people in terms of my appearance I've
been compared to like a younger version
of Gaspar I've been compared to this TV
show called Nathan for you
who else Robin Williams I think mr. bean
whatever okay um thanks everyone for
watching before I go I'll have to find
someone to host can I host
Eric Hanson who's streaming can I go to
twitch quickly check I'm gonna do a
search for chess mmm
or is anyone streaming on me chess Oh
let's go watch and streamers I want to
host someone I know but I don't know any
of these people twitch TV this is gonna
be weird for a moment - chess let's do a
search I'm sure there's other people
from that tournament who are streaming I
[Music]
should know someone here oh there's some
foreign people streaming - um what does
this guy oh he just ended no I want to
find a streamer who speaks English uh
someone's streaming on chess 24 oh does
eart booj I think desert booj has like
has been a pretty loyal viewer so I
don't know what he's doing is he doing
atomic chess all host hazard desert booj
I have to go back to twitch oh no I can
do it from the chat okay so host desert
Oh someone's asking a question Rieman is
saying is our story behind you saying I
take d5 and so if Knight takes d5 is
there a difference
take or takes I mean night take d5s take
slightly more effort to say wait what
did I just say if you add the s it takes
slightly more effort so it's easier just
to say take now I'm confusing myself
let's end the stream here hosting desert
booj actually raiding desert foods there
we go and I'll see everyone later